being with the original ghostbusters was
really like special the new ghostbusters
is here paving a future for the
franchise while using the classics from
the actors all the way to the gadgets
very much worth it it looks so good on
screen the iconic ecto goggles from the
original ghostbusters make an appearance
in the afterlife film as well
they look just incredible but for logan
kim it was very inconvenient since he
couldn't actually see with the goggles
on so when he was acting he literally we
had to like be like look a little left
otherwise he just even know where to
look
luckily the actor made it out totally
unharmed but we can imagine if there's a
sequel he'll be requesting a functional
pair of goggles
it's been a few years since bill murray
sported the classic proton pack and it
wasn't quite like it used to be
murray really suffered feeling a lot of
pain wearing the pack because of how
uncomfortable it was they're pretty
they're very heavy for distant and stunt
shots the actors got to wear a lighter
version of the packs but for any
close-ups it was the real 30 pound deal
like half the weight in what they were
in 1984 the pack was fully equipped with
rumble motors and batteries so those
blasters could jolt and shake in the
actor's hands
driving the ecto-1 was a major throwback
to the original and no doubt a very
special experience for finn wolfhard but
unfortunately the actor didn't get the
chance to fully get behind the wheel he
tried to get his license but
twice i failed wolfhard did get to be in
control of the car as it moved just a
few mere inches but it was still amazing
for the actor a stunt driver took the
reins for the movie controlling the
accelerator and brakes of the totally
souped-up vehicle making this movie was
a multi-year commitment
a year before they even went to camera
the team got into some gardening i was
in the car and it's a real wheat field
that like they planted a year before um
so that we could just rip through it the
house used in the movie was fully real
inside and out and this was where so
many of the scenes were filmed not a
corner was cut here making this movie a
full-time job
ghostbusters afterlife has the best of
both worlds the original cast we know
and love and new actors embodying the
next generation it was amazing it was
really special yeah it didn't really
feel real but it was incredibly special
for the newbies being amid all that
history was definitely something special
it was like a bunch of brothers like
coming back together it was really sweet
this new story has revitalized a
nostalgic franchise brilliantly it's a
fresh take on it all while the new cast
members no doubt felt a ton of pressure
they definitely rose to the challenge a
lot of it is practical step aside cgi
ghostbusters are in town and they like
to keep it retro honoring the original
movies the team relied on good
old-fashioned filming techniques
like puppets and
animatronics wires magnets illusions
if it ain't broke don't fix it a
surprisingly vital tool used throughout
the movie was wind and since they were
kicking at old school the team had a lot
of supplies we had a truck that was only
fan while a major emphasis was put on
practical creations cgi did become key
in bringing one very special and pretty
major element to the movie
one of the most impressive characters we
see in afterlife is the legendary terror
dog and wanting to stay true to the
roots of the film the creature was
brought to life by a mix of practical
and special effects
the only thing cooler than watching it
on screen is actually being on set and
watching the terror dog come to life the
terror dog was a specially built puppet
operated by one of the best puppeteers
in the world this added to the
experience and really made the world of
the movie come to life being the son of
the creator of such a legendary
franchise leaves some pretty big shoes
to fill but luckily jason rickman had
the best right-hand man he could ask for
ivan ritman
such a
family
legacy
his dad was literally right beside him
the whole time giving the director a
very special experience
though sometimes he could feel a bit
overwhelmed by his dad's presence in a
professional setting but at the end of
the day it was a fascinating and
extremely memorable experience as both a
filmmaker and son it is really a gift
that i got to make this movie with him
it wouldn't be ghostbusters without
ghosts but this time we've got muncher
and his casting was totally spontaneous
but it was a perfect match since the
actor just happened to be a major
ghostbusters fan so how did this
serendipitous casting come about josh
and i ran into each other on the sony
lot director jason reitman asked if josh
gad was interested in voicing the ghost
and was delighted when the actor
immediately said yes and went straight
into the studio to record all the
gadgets we see in the film were made to
be as close as possible to the original
ones
as for their references
the real props we were able to get our
hands on the 84 props the team got to
take lidar scans of all those pieces
from the 1984 movie allowing them to
make perfectly accurate replicas to use
we wanted the whole film to be original
recipe ghostbusters the car was put
together with parts found from around
the world mckenna grace even got to wear
the same glasses frames that harold
ramis wore in the original movie i was
just having a great time like just
flying back and forth
while the young actors did have stunt
doubles much of the time the performers
just go straight into their roles um i
got to do some stunts the actress had
never done stunts this intense before
but she bravely dove into wire work and
actually flew across the field protected
of course and landing safely on a
cushiony pad honestly
it really was just like pure excitement
logan kim had quite the unique
experience on set we're not at all
surprised that this was his favorite
scene to film i got to be covered in
marshmallow which was not really
marshmallow as for paul rudd
the whole thing really was fun but boy
going into that store and shooting a
scene
nothing could beat the scene in the mall
featuring the one and only marshmallows
and of course the terror dog he hired a
bagpiper to follow
him
yes
that quote actually has something to do
with the ghostbusters afterlife film
when bill murray's birthday came around
he showed up to set accompanied by an
actual bagpiper but here's the catch the
actor pretended as if the musician
wasn't there at all if that wasn't wild
enough he was singing some
scottish or irish song
to everyone with the bagpiper so how did
the actors deal with this strange
occasion everybody started singing with
him this set was a definite party
and not just for birthdays the now 70
year old actor bill murray was hesitant
about diving back into the franchise he
first starred in decades ago but after
reading the script he knew it was worth
being a part of because of just how much
heart and emotion there was in the story
his concern was fair considering just
how hard the filming wound up being on
him with all the physical action and
wild filming conditions like wind and
dirt this special project has been kept
quite secretive from the very start when
finn wolfhard first auditioned he had no
idea he was reading for none other than
ghostbusters afterlife
it came through as like untitled sony
project since the actor had already
experienced being a ghostbuster in
stranger things he worried he wouldn't
end up getting the role but much to
everyone's delight the job was his
nostalgia a stellar cast and
ghostbusters
we couldn't ask for a more exciting
lineup which special retro gadget would
you want to have